[MUSIC PLAYING]
NASEER MOHAMMAD: Welcome to
"Apigee Up Close" webinar
series.
They happen twice a month.
The topics are based
on popular demand.
You can ask live questions
or send them in advance.
And I am Naseer Mohammad,
a customer solution
architect at Google, and I
specialize in API security.
Joining me in this webinar is
Chris Page, a customer solution
architect.
As a part of agenda
today, I will
start with a brief
overview of Apigee Edge,
then we'll deep dive into
Apigee Edge Security,
and then I will hand
it over to Chris,
who will demonstrate the threat
protection aspect of security.
While we are doing so,
please post your questions,
and we will answer
them at the end.
Let's start with a quick
Apigee Edge overview.
This is our design
philosophy at Apigee.
This challenges traditional
approaches of API management.
Traditionally, we think
about this from an exposure
point of view--
they expose a set of services
and publish an API catalog,
and they think the job is done.
Well, not really.
Thinking about it from
an end user point of view
and working backwards from
there leads to better results.
Realizing the importance of
each actor on this chain,
and providing them with
enhanced experiences,
becomes the key for a
successful API program.
This outside-in approach is the
underlying principle at Apigee,
using which we have shown great
success to many of our clients.
Having said that,
let's change the lens
and look at this pattern from
a security point of view.
Indeed, the pattern
covers a lot of ground,
which opens up a
need for a larger
set of security controls.
Each actor on this
chain has a unique set
of security requirements.
Let us start from left
to right, following
the outside-in approach.
As we publish our
APIs for end users,
how can we protect
these APIs from hackers
who are trying to
bring our systems down,
and from data scrapers
and bad bots who
wants to steal our data?
Thereby leading to the
next question-- how can
I know that incoming calls
are from legit users,
and do they really
have needed permissions
to access these APIs?
An enterprise can
have many applications
that access your APIs--
how can I uniquely identify
these applications?
More importantly, as we are
looking at it from a security
and governance
perspective, how can I
ensure that the
decommissioned apps
can no longer access this API?
Moving further in towards
the right of the chain
comes the app developer.
App developer uses our APIs
to create great applications.
Now, how can we onboard
these app developers?
Remember, these
app developers can
be internal employees,
third party partners,
and any developer
on the internet.
How can we register
him and provide him
with needed access
without much friction?
Moving towards the
APIs and API teams,
how do we ensure that the
API developers are developing
APIs that are secure and are not
opening up any vulnerability?
Are they adhering to
enterprise security standards?
Finally, on the backend, how
do we authenticate backend?
How do we pass in the
originating user's information
to the backend services?
How do we secure data on
wire and data at rest?
Yeah, the list is long.
We need an API platform that
provides effective solution
for all these questions.
Apigee, as a comprehensive
API platform,
provides standards-based
adaptive security controls,
addressing those diverse set
of security requirements.
Apigee protects against hackers
and data scrapers leveraging
the Apigee Sense module, which
is a behavior-based threat
protection module.
Apigee protects our APIs against
threatening content attacks
like SQL injections,
cross-site scripting attacks,
leveraging the signature-based
type protection policy.
Apigee effectively
controls spikes in traffic,
thereby protecting our backend
services from going down.
Apigee identifies the
applications based on API keys
and authenticates end user
leveraging the industry
standard OAuth protocol.
After identification
and authentication
comes the challenge
of API authorization.
Apigee introduces this
concept of products.
API products help
you slice and dice
your APIs in ways that
makes business sense.
These products, in turn, act
as cross-grain authorization
enforcers.
For final grain authorization,
Apigee leverages OAuth scopes.
Apart from that, products
have assigned quotas
for enforcing usage boundaries.
And last but not the
least, logging capabilities
for auditability, thus covering
identification, authentication,
authorization, and auditability
aspects of security.
Apigee works with your identity
and access management products,
like SideWinders, Ping
[INAUDIBLE] et cetera,
for providing single sign-on
and self-service experiences
for your app developers.
Apigee supports OpenId Connect,
JWT, and SAML protocols
to work with your partners
in a federated fashion.
Apigee provides global
policies and flow hooks
for abstracting
development and enforcement
of security policies from
business API developers.
Apigee provides developer portal
as well as management APIs
for provisioning and
decommissioning apps
and application developers.
Apigee secures data on
wire and in-transit,
leveraging one-way
and two-way SSL.
Apigee can also store your
sensitive configuration
elements in an
encrypted fashion,
thereby providing
confidentiality
of your purchaser data.
This is a high level overview
of Apigee security landscape.
In this webinar, we will
concentrate on the threat
protection policies.
With that, I will
hand it over to Chris.
CHRIS PAGE: Hi, I'm Chris Page.
I'm a customer solution
architect on the Apigee team,
which is part of Google Cloud.
Today, I'm going to
showcase how Apigee Edge
can be configured to protect
against threat protection.
So the problem is when
a malicious client
can send malformed requests
to your backend services,
as showcased in
my diagram below.
This includes all components
that make up the HTTP request
or message from those
clients, whether it
be TLS certificates, request
headers, the payload, or even
the query string fields
and/or parameters.
And our client can be anything.
It can be a browser,
mobile device, a server,
or even a IoT device.
The API proxy layer should
detect, block, and report
any malformed requests that
are received from those clients
before the requests
are processed
on the backend systems.
Too often, this is an oversight
and is not implemented, or not
even a priority when
developers are building out
backend systems.
OWASP, which is the Open Web
Application Security Project,
is an open community that
is dedicated to enabling
organizations to implement web
API security best practices.
OWASP publishes a top 10 list
of the most critical security
risks to web
applications and APIs.
Their latest
publication last year
labeled injection flaws as
the number one security risk.
In this demo, we'll cover
two of those topics.
Input validation, which--
user-supplied data is not
validated, filtered,
or sanitized
before the application
receives it.
It should only be applied to
both syntactical and semantic
levels--
that's structured fields
and/or in value ranges, i.e.
only permit valid payloads
or depths and lengths.
Key, value is one depth,
whereas key 2, key 3
would be multiple depths.
And also, validate query
parameter fields, i.e.,
for this demo, I'm only going
to validate the limit, name,
and brewery key fields.
Another example
of injection flaws
is SQL code injection, i.e.
when dynamic queries are calls
without any contextual where
escaping are used to
directly hit the interpreter
or the application
context, i.e.,
let's search on the filter
for parameter values where
name='DELETE from resource.'
This can be applied in addition
to not just relational,
but also NoSQL queries.
And a lot of times, it can
be implemented on ORM levels,
or object relational mappings--
abstraction layers
from a database
that may have direct SQL
queries implemented as well.
Now, in this diagram,
on the right-hand side,
there is a RESTful Beer service
that is returning valid JSON
data to client.
We want to only allow good
requests from valid clients
and detect, block, and
report on the bad requests
from those malicious clients.
The goals are create
an API that protects
against those injection flaws
from the client requests,
payloads, and query parameters,
keep it as simple as possible,
make it reproducible
for any additional APIs,
and also be able to
report on the usage
of those malformed requests.
Now let's get to the API.
Let's log into my
Apigee Edge account
and take a look at the
proxy that I've already
created for this demo.
My proxy, my Beers proxy,
already has a deployment URL.
You can see my FQDN here with
the endpoint of forward slash
v1/beer.
Here's my target endpoint on
my backend Beer service called
v1/beer-backend.
Once-- let's take a look
at the actual policies
that we can run through
with this proxy.
You'll see that I have
a couple of policies
that are already defined here.
Out of the box,
Apigee Edge includes
a whole suite of palettes--
or a whole palette
of different policy
assertions [INAUDIBLE]
traffic management, security,
mediation for transformation,
as well as extendability.
Today, we're just going to
focus on a couple of the threat
protections--
JSON Threat Protection
for input and validation,
as well as SQL Code
Protection and Parameter
Validation for injection flaws.
So on my Details flow,
I've already went ahead
and created the JSON Threat
Protection, a parameter
validation leveraging
a JavaScript callout.
I also have a custom fault
detection for that JavaScript
Parameter Validation, and
then also SQL Code Protection.
In a real world
production API proxy,
you would also have
some AuthN-AuthZ
to identify the client,
as well as any IP
tables or
restriction-based rules
before any of these
additional policies.
Let's take a look at JSON Threat
Protection as our first policy.
We'll see there's a couple
different parameters
or variables that
are defined here.
Our ArrayElementCount
is the first one.
That means that this JSON
threat structure will not
include any arrays.
It will just actually
be a key value.
And the depth of
those values will just
be 1, so there won't
be any nested depth
or nested key value objects
within the JSON structure.
We want to keep the number of
keys or the number of entries
to 3, and we're going to
keep the length of those keys
down to 50.
In addition, we're going to
limit the value of those keys
to only be 255 characters.
Now, Apigee Edge provides
a real-time trace debugger,
so we can actually go
ahead and start looking
at the requests coming in.
I'll start with a couple
of successful requests
so that you can see that nothing
is going to be triggered,
and then simulate some of the
input validation and injection
flaws.
Just minimize this.
Awesome.
So first, let's just
do a simple get.
Oh, there's a return.
Let's actually limit
to one resource.
There is a simple
beer coming back.
Let's try a filter.
Equals 2.
Excellent.
You'll see that the first three
requests came through as 200s.
I can ignore that fat
finger 404 that I just did.
If we do a simple POST,
let's create a new beer.
We'll just have its
simple name be--
I have a POST with
application content--
or content type application
JSON, meaning the payload
is a JSON structure with name
and the value the best beer.
See I got a 201 return
back from my response.
Perfect.
Everything looks good.
Now let's try and
actually simulate
some of that input validation
to trigger those policies
that I already have enabled.
So for JSON Threat
Protection, let's
run through two examples
of, let's do nested JSON
and extremely
large key values so
that we can trigger and
identify which ones are actually
being captured.
So first things first,
let's try that POST again.
This time, I'm going to
do a nested structure
as my value instead of
just a standard name.
Oh, immediately I got a 400 back
from my Apigee Edge API proxy.
You'll see that I have a
custom faultstring or fault
message that is actually
identifying the policy itself,
which is JSONThreatProtection,
and more details of "exceeded
the container depth at line 1."
And we look at our trace
session and there's that 400.
And if you walk
through the trace path,
you'll see that that
JSONThreatProtection
was triggered right here.
Excellent.
Now, what if I have a
random array of strings
that are over 255 characters?
Let's try that same POST
method, this time with--
there it is, a 400
immediately back
from Apigee Edge
in my API proxy,
and you'll see the same
policy was triggered,
JSONThreatProtection,
with a different value,
though, this time--
"exceeded string value
length at line 1."
Likewise, there it is--
I got the error right here
on the JSONThreatProtection.
Now, each time that
actually occurs,
I'm actually doing some
additional logging.
You'll see these
other policies here
that I'll get into where I'm
going to capture those error
codes and we'll be able
to report them later.
But this showcases that with
a simple drag and drop policy,
you can configure and have
those parameters you'd
find to [INAUDIBLE] against
JSON threats or within the key
as well as the value in
the structure itself.
Now, for the next
example, let's take
a look at SQL code
injection flaws,
as well as URL
parameter query strings.
So let's go back to my policies
on my detail policy flow.
Now, I have a couple
of additional policies
out next to my JSON
Threat Protection.
The first one is
Parameter Validation,
and for Parameter
Validation, I'm
actually going to leverage
our JavaScript callout
feature where I can write
custom JavaScript and custom
logic within Apigee Edge
to manipulate the message
or session, as well as
define custom variables
from the requests coming in.
So within my Paramter
Validation JavaScript,
I'm actually going to create
a whiteList of parameters
or query strings that are only
valid for my backend client.
In this case, I only want to
allow the query string name,
brewery, and limit to be
able to be passed back
to my backend resource.
I set a custom
faultResponse message
here so that I can capture it if
this ParameterValidation threat
protection is triggered,
and I'm actually
going to go and iterate
over the request parameters.
I'll iterate over
the whiteList to see
if any of those
request parameters
meet one of those
variables in the whiteList,
and then if I'll flag one--
If they're true, they're good.
If not, I'll flag them as
false and I'll actually
set a context variable called
parameterValidation.fault
to set a custom fault
message so that I
can report on that accordingly.
Once that custom fault message
is set, I'll actually raise--
I'll set a custom parameter
validation fault message here
to be able to report
on that accordingly.
Let's go back to
my trace session.
We're still running.
Great.
Let's simulate a successful call
again with those query strings.
We'll see there's that best
beer variable that I just
created earlier.
Now, if I change my
query parameter--
in addition to limit and name,
if I add, let's say, test=123,
which was not a valid parameter,
immediately I get a 400 back
from my Apigee Edge API proxy.
And here's a
different definition
or a different policy--
"ParameterValidation.
Execution failed,
reason-- 'test'
is not a valid parameter."
That is true.
That wasn't one of those
whitelisted parameters
that I defined in my
JavaScript callout.
And you'll see right here that
the JSONThreatProtection was
not triggered, but the
actual ParameterValidation
went through.
It iterated over
those three values,
and then I set this fault
that this was triggered,
and then I caught that fault
and I raised the fault based
off my ParameterValidation.
Just as like that, you
can have whitelisted
parameters that
you can call out,
in addition to JSON Threat
Protection for injection flaws.
Now, what if the client is going
to send those malformed SQL
code?
Let's go back to my policy,
and here is SQL code.
This is actually a SQL
Code Protection policy
where I'm allowing Apigee
Edge to identify the invalid
SQL that is being
sent by the values
of those query
parameters with a name.
So whether it be the query,
the header, or the form,
I am looking-- at I
have a set regex which
was defined by OWASP where
delete, execute, drop, insert,
shut down, or update, or any of
those standard relational SQL
or NoSQL queries can be
captured and this policy
can be triggered.
So let's take another example.
Let's go back to
my trace session.
So if I do a get, this
time, let's change
name to be DELETE from brewery.
Let's try that.
Oh, just like that.
Once again, I got another 400
back from my Apigee Edge API
proxy.
And you'll see this time, it's
regular expression detected,
and actually, am identifying
DELETE from brewery
was invalid parameter,
or invalid value
for that parameter.
I can go back to
my trace session.
Let's skip over
here, and you'll see
that the SQLCodeProtection was
actually triggered this time.
And just like that, I just--
in those three policies,
I was able to do
input validation
through nested JSON
and JSON string length,
as well as injection flaws from
query parameters and SQL code
injection failures.
Now, I did mention that
I needed to capture--
I had some additional policies
to capture those analytics,
because the idea
of the API proxy
is not just to detect and
block those threat protections,
but also report on them, too.
So I have these additional
FaultResponse flows right down
here where I'm going to extract
the error codes that are coming
back from this file response.
And I'm going to try and
capture that error code variable
so that I can report on them
through our Apigee Edge's
analytics.
Now, that value right
here is actually
just a key value error
code with the value
here is steps.regexprotection.
And if I look at
the other one, it
is steps.parametervalidation.
So within this policy, I'm
actually doing a JSONPath
on that variable or on that
detail error code variable,
and then saving
that as a context
variable called FaultErrorCode.
That FaultErrorCode
is now going to be
leveraged through
our FaultCollector.
And this FaultCollector
is basically
a statistics collector that
will capture that variable
and set it as a new value
within our analytics
so that I can report on it.
So that FaultErrorCode
variable will actually
be set as fault_error_code
within my analytics.
I went ahead and
created a report.
So let's see if
that is available.
It reports on those
error codes based off
of the sum of traffic.
So if I go into this report--
oh, there it is.
You'll see that I am
capturing each one of them.
Looks like there's the
threatprotection, here's
the parametervalidation,
here's the regexprotection.
Looks like I have a
couple ones that are not
set that I'll have to go back
and clean up to make sure
that they're not being
sent anonymously.
But just like that,
you're able to protect
within Apigee Edge for threat
protection injection flaws
as well as input
validation, and then
report on them within
our analytics platform.
And that concludes this demo.
Thanks you very much, and let me
know if you have any questions.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: Thank you for
really, really wonderful demo
there.
All right, so we'll take a pause
here for question and answers.
So guys, please do
ask your questions.
I'll be pouring through
the Q&A channel here.
So the first question in
here goes as follows--
"Can Apigee be configured
to detect false positives
while performing
signature-based threats?
Using our current [INAUDIBLE]
and cloud-based firewall,
we can block the calls that
have threatening signatures,
but they do not tell us
why the calls were blocked.
Can Apigee provide
additional information
on why the request was blocked?"
So that's the question.
And so we have seen this
before from many of our clients
as well who are using
[INAUDIBLE] or any firewall
in the network side.
When it comes to threatening
content protection,
it is very important for us
to get the signatures right.
At times, what
happens is you might
have a signature or a
[INAUDIBLE] expression that
corresponds to a signature, and
it might also capture or mark
the requests that are not
really threatening content,
because they do not really
have any content that
was threatening but
was a false positive.
So yes, in Apigee,
you can configure
your threatening content
policies to report back
onto why the call was blocked,
thereby your developers
can go back and can see
why the call was blocked,
or it can go to your analytics
consoles or your logging
systems whereby the operations
folks can go and see
why a particular transaction
was [? designed. ?]
Hope that answers that question.
So the next question
I have here is,
can Apigee be integrated with
cloud-based identity solutions
like Okta?
Yes, we have many
times we're using Okta
and are also using Apigee
for API management.
The general answer--
like yes, the answer
is yes for Okta, but in
general, for any cloud identity
solution, as long as the cloud
identity provider supports
a SAML protocol or
OpenId Connect protocol,
we can work with them.
We have also worked with some of
the cloud providers that really
do not support a fully
OpenId Connect protocol,
but they have OAuth
implementation, which
we can integrate with as well.
So the short answer
is yes, we support
Okta, the cloud-based
identity solution.
So there's another
question here--
how can I configure
behavior-based threat
protection modules?
Like, where can I
set the upper limits
and lower limits of, for
example, a brute force attack?
All right, so
that's interesting.
So what we have seen
in this demo today
is signature-based
threat protection, right?
So there's also a
complementary aspect
of signature-based
protection, which
is also known as [INAUDIBLE]
behavior-based threat
protection.
Apigee has a product
called Apigee Sense that
does provide those capabilities,
and Apigee Sense provides--
basically, what
it provides you--
settings that are based
on convention, based
on our experiences, as to
how you mark a certain attack
as a brute force attack
or a password guesser
attack [INAUDIBLE]
And then out of those
settings, we give full control
to our customers to come and
fine tune those settings based
on their needs.
So yes, Apigee does provide
you configuration capabilities
to configure your adaptive
behavior-based detection
algorithms based on your inputs.
So I hope that
answers that question.
CHRIS PAGE: OK,
let me check on one
of these other next questions.
Does SQL Code Protection only
apply to relational databases?
Now that's-- you
know, yes and no.
There's a common misconception
that if developers are not
writing SQL queries for
their SQL databases,
that SQL code injection
is really not applicable.
There are definitely
well-known SQL vulnerabilities
via associated arrays
and where clauses.
You can definitely check out on
some of the black hat and OWASP
websites.
But there's some documentation
for testing against SQL code
on NoSQL data stores.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: Sounds good.
So the next question
that is in here
is should an ORM database
framework library handle
all SQL injection protection?
That's a good question.
So the best practice
for security
is to block the
threatening content
before it comes to
your folder [INAUDIBLE]
on the database side.
So for example, let's
say your ORM basically
is searching your internet
right where the data is.
So the fact that the
threatening content vector
reached and managed to reach at
that level in itself is a risk.
So we definitely want to
have our ORM databases
to implement SQL
injection protections,
but it should be handled on the
edge of the API gateway layers
so that we provide at the
first level of defense, which
is our API gateway,
making sure that there's
no threatening vectors or
[INAUDIBLE] signatures that
are coming in and
protected over there.
So the answer is yes, the
protection should be on the ORM
as well.
But it is always best
practice to protect the calls
at the edge layers.
So I'll take up the second--
the next question as well here.
Can Apigee prevent
malicious requests,
or can it only detect?
If it can prevent, can these
prevented malicious calls
be reported to our
incident management teams?
That's a good question.
So yes, Apigee is
both detection--
works both as a detection
and prevention mechanisms.
So it has protective controls
and it has preventive controls
as well.
Apigee can very well, like Chris
showed in the demonstration,
can detect and prevent and
block the call right there.
If you want, Apigee can also
detect and record the call.
I think that that's
the question-- that's
where the question was
leading towards, right?
So it can definitely detect and
notify an incident management
team to take
appropriate actions.
Obviously, the
preferred approach
is to prevent and detect in
Apigee and after detection,
block the call and then notify
to the incident management team
so that the incident
management team can
take the appropriate
actions on that.
Hope that answers that question.
Chris, you want to
go for the next one?
CHRIS PAGE: Sure.
Do you-- here's the question.
Do you have to have
customized SQL injection
regex for threat protection,
or something universal which
can be used?
So there's a wide range
of threat protections
that can be identified
from the communities,
and there isn't one unique
regex that would solve all.
So you would basically define
those unique regex patterns
based off of that
particular threat.
This next one-- is there
a list of out of the box
security policies that
you would recommend
to use as a starting
point for most APIs?
Now, that's a good question.
A lot of the times,
we hear that--
what are those best practices--
from our customers, of what
security policies should
be applied to those APIs.
And it's really going to
depend what type of API it is.
Is it a SOAP-based service?
Is it a RESTful service?
You know, is it a public-facing,
is it an internal API?
We have a lot of those
protections we would definitely
implement for those APIs
right out of the box.
We also have a couple of other
policies within our palette
that we didn't go into
depth within this tutorial
or this webinar.
Something like verifying client
quota or rate limiting or spike
arrests would also be
applied as best practices.
And you can find
out more of them
through our community and our
doc sites within the Resources
tab.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: I
have two questions here
which are related.
How do you validate the
input request parameters
with the data types?
Example, if I want
to send H paramaters,
I would not like to take
a [INAUDIBLE] input.
So that question and
the question about also,
can you validate the URL
parameters and body payloads
validating against
a JSON schema?
So it also-- it's a data
validation question.
Yes, you can validate your
input incoming request, again,
like JSON schema or XML schema,
and the schema validation
is definitely very good step
for you to validate the data.
You can definitely do that.
What you can also do is, because
we are focused on threatening
content protection,
we can also validate
the complexity of the JSON.
There are a few attacks that
are sophisticated in the nature
that they try to emulate
a denial of service attack
by sending a huge JSON
payload or an XML payload that
your backends cannot handle.
So Apigee can definitely--
rapidly handles
complexity policy
wherein you can define
your complexity levels,
saying that the allowed max
cap on a number of elements
in a JSON payload
is less than 50.
So anyone who's trying
to send more than that,
we will mark that as a threat
so that we can do that.
So the answer is
yes, data validation
can be done via schema, XML
schemas and JSON schemas.
You can actually go find way and
then you pick the query params
or should it be headers
and also validate
the data using
[INAUDIBLE] filters.
And then who can take that
to the next level, where
you're also adding
the complexity
filters on top of it.
Hope that answers that question.
CHRIS PAGE: These
are great questions.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: I
think, Chris, we went
through all the questions here.
There is another
question also that says,
I want to be an
expert in Apigee.
What do I need to do?
So you know, Apigee has--
so the first thing
you have to do
is log in, create an
account, start using Apigee.
The more you use, the more
use cases you implement,
the more you learn about
the product itself.
But having said
that, if you want
to become an expert in
Apigee, you also broaden
your view of API platform.
It's not just the API gateway.
There's more to it, right?
Like we started in
the slide, there's
a developer portal in Apigee.
There's also our
recommendations on how
do you document your API,
how do you publish your API.
You know, apart
from security, there
are more other features that
are there that Apigee provides.
There are also regional API
Jam sessions, which we can--
you are free to join any
of those sessions, wherein
it's a one day session.
You come in, and I think it's
a [? firework ?] station where
it's a deep dive
into the product.
You're basically building
APIs, configuring
your recorders and all that.
By the end of that, you would
actually become an API ninja.
So look on-- watch out for these
API, regional API Jam sessions.
If you want a specific API jam
session for your organization,
you're more than welcome
to send out a request
and we'll do the
best to cater that.
CHRIS PAGE: Looks like
there's about one or two
more questions.
And I can take these, Naseer.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: Sure, go ahead.
CHRIS PAGE: Why isn't the client
authenticated before the threat
protections?
I guess-- I think
the way I interpret
it is, why is the client not
identified before the threat
protections are
implemented or exercised?
Well, in the real world,
API security best practices,
yes, the client really
should be authenticated
before inspecting that
payload queries, et cetera,
to identify really which
client and what client
is sending the malicious data.
Best practices are fail
fast before requiring
additional system resources
for inspection of the request
payload.
Typically, AuthN
or AuthZ will be
covered in a future "Apigee Up
Close" and security webinar.
How can you monitor--
next question, how can you
monitor malicious clients
in pattern matching
or rule-based filters?
That's a great one.
Apigee does have a product
called Apigee Sense, which
does specifically that.
It applies adaptive
API security product
to mitigate sophisticated
bot attacks.
It leverages machine learning
and detects anomalies
based off pattern
matching at the API layer.
[INAUDIBLE] the ability to
create dynamic rules or custom
rules based off of
that pattern matching
that the product provides.
Also enables you to take
action on those bots
you find, whether
it be throttle,
block, log, et cetera.
And we also have another
session with an Apigee Sense
that is coming up in
a couple of weeks.
I think that's it
for the questions.
Appreciate everyone's input.
I'd just like to leave off with
some follow up documentation.
Our next webcast is
Tuesday, March 6--
"How Secure Are Your APIs?"
We also have an
in-depth tutorial
you can join via
our Virtual API Jam.
And for any one on one sessions
or additional questions,
please reach out to
Michael Lofquist.
His email is mlofquist--
L-O-F-Q-U-I-S-T-- at google.com.
And all additional
documentation links
are in the Resources section.
And that's a wrap.
We appreciate everyone
joining this webcast today
and look forward to
seeing the next one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]